[موسيقى]
ينعقد في عمان الثلاثاء وبرعاية
لجوء الى خيارات اخرى لم يسميها في حال
فشل الرباعيه في استئناف
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المفاوضات حياكم الله نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في عنوانين رئيسيين ما هي افق
التحركات الاخيره اللجنه الرباعيه وما
الدافع وراء عودتها في هذا التوقيت وما
دلالات وضع عباس مهله محدده لاستئناف
المفاوضات وما خياراته اذا لم
تستانف بعد انقطاع دام 16 شهرا في مسار
المفاوضات الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه يجتمع
في عمان الطرفان الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي في
اطار اجتماع للجنه الرباعيه الدوليه جاء
ثمره لجهود العاهل الاردني الملك عبد الله
الثاني الاجتماع الذي اكد الطرفان ان هدفه
تسليم مقترحاته حول قضيتي الحدود والامن
وانه لا يعني باي حال العوده الى
المفاوضات ياتي قبل يومين فقط من تهديدات
باللجوء الى خيارات اخرى في حال فشلت
اللجنه الرباعيه في استئناف
المفاوضات البعض يسميها مفاوضات السلام
المباشره بينما يحلو للامريكيين تسميتها
عمليه السلام في الشرق الاوسط وايا كانت
التسميات فطا وه المفاوضات في الاردن
تستعد للقاء فلسطيني اسرائيلي طال انتظاره
وقيل انه لقاء لطرح الرؤى والحلول سيكون
اللقاء هذه المره مباشرا دون وسيط للمره
الاولى منذ عام 2009 عندما تحطمت اخر
جلسات التفاوض في نيويورك على صخره
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه محبطه رغبه
امريكيه في فرض مناخ تفاوضي في الشرق
الاوسط باي ثمن واليوم وبعد انشغال
المنطقه بربيع الثوري الممتد الى اجل غير
مسمى يدخل الاردن على خط الوساطه في ملف
المفاوضات الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه للمره
الاولى منذ 16 شهرا ليثير تساؤلات عن
اسباب هذا الحضور المفاجئ بعد فتره صمت
طويله العاهل الاردني يدع الرباعيه
الدوليه التي اقتصر نشاطها خلال عامين على
مجرد الحديث عن استئناف مفاوضات يدعوها
الى اجتماع في الاردن بحضور ممثلين عن
الجانبين الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني دعوه تلاقي دعما امريكيا
اوروبيا في وقت يحاول فيه الامريكيون
اخراج اسرائيل من عزلتها الاقليميه على
خلفيه علاقات مرتبكه مع الحلفاء
الاستراتيجيين في مصر وتركيا فلما لا تكون
المفاوضات بوابه تنفتح اسرائيل من خلالها
على محيطها مجددا غير ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه لن تنتظر طويلا حتى يتم
استئناف هذه المفاوضات والحديث ليس فقط
الى اسرائيل بل الى الرباعيه ايضا من هنا
ل 26 واح اذا لم تتمكن الرباعيه من وضع
الطرفين على طاوله المفاوضات على اسس
واضحه معناها ان الرباعيه فشلت ما دام
فشلت نحن سيكون لنا موقف لم يوضح الرئيس
الفلسطيني خياراته المتاحه للضغط على
اسرائيل لا سما بعد فشل مساعيه في مجلس
الامن الدولي للاعتراف بالدوله الفلسطينيه
وبعد استبعاده خيار انتفاضه ثالثه وبغض
النظر عن فاعليه ما سيطرح من حلول فهناك
رغبه داخل اسرائيل وخارجها في تحريك
المفاوضات المجمده في وقت بدا فيه العد
التنازلي لانتخابات
امريكيه لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من رم
الله عزام الاحمد عضو اللجنه المركزيه
لحركه فتح من عمان معنا عريب الرنتاوي
مدير مركز القدس للدراسات السياسيه ابدا
معك سيد عزام الاحمد اذا افترضنا ان
اسرائيل تذهب لهذا الاجتماع لانها تريد ان
تخرج من عزلتها والولايات المتحده
والرباعيه تريدان ان تعودان للمنطقه من
خلاله انتم لماذا تذهبون
لعمان
يعني بشكل
واضح هذا الاجتماع بناء على اقتراح
اردني جرى التشاور فيه بين القياده الف
فلسطينيه والقياده الاردنيه حرص الاردن
الشقيق على استمرار عمليه السلام وضمان
الحقوق المشروعه للشعب الفلسطيني هو
المحرك للقياده الاردنيه وبالتالي نحن
نقدر هذه الجهود من الجانب الاردني خاصه
انا للاسف اللجنه الرباعيه عاجزه منذ فتره
طويله على اتخاذ مواقف ضحه تحمل الاطراف
وخاصه الطرف الاسرائيلي على الانخراط في
عمليه سلام واضحه وجديه تؤدي الى نتائج
عمليه الاردن تدرك المخاطر الناجمه عن
جمود عمليه السلام تدرك المخاطر التي قد
تترتب على ما يمكن ان يحصل بعد 26 واحد
وهو الموعد الذي حددته اللجنه الرباعيه
لتسلم
الردود اسرائيل حاولت كعادتها ان
اي تكسب الوقت تضيع الوقت تسوف تقول انها
لا تريد ان ترسل الرد الا على طاوله
المفاوضات حصل اجتهاد ان هذا الاجتماع
بوجود الطرفين امام اللجنه الرباعيه
ومشاركه الاردن الطرفين مطلوب منهما ان
يسلما ردودهم حول موضوع الحدود والامن
بشكل واضح وفق ما جاء في بيان الرباعيه
الصادر في 23 سبتمبر الماضي نحن لا نرغب
بالجمود
وذلك نحن الملخص السلطه عريب العنتوت تذهب
الى عمان لتسليم اوراق اذا لماذا كل هذه
الضجه والايحاء بان هناك ما يشير الى تقدم
حقيقي في مسار المفاوضات
ليس هناك ما يشير الى اي تقدم جدي في مسار
المفاوضات ولست متفائلا بالنتائج التي سوف
تترتب على لقاء عمان هذا اللقاء هو محاوله
ربع الساعه الاخير ان لم يقن محاوله
المحاوله في الوقت الضائع والمستقطع نحن
امام استحقاق 26
يناير الاستحقاق النهائي الذي حددته
الرباعيه الدوليه نقترب من هذا الاستحقاق
وتخ بال الساحه الفلسطينيه من اجراء
المراجعات المطلوبه في هذا المجال الفجوه
التي اطاحت بعمليه المفاوضات والسلام في
السابق ما زالت قائمه وتتسع اكثر في اكثر
ليس في اسرائيل شريك لعمليه السلام
اسرائيل ليست بوارد القبول
بمرجع خط الرابع من حزيران ولا هي على
استعداد لوقف الاستيطان اسرائيل ماضيه في
تهويد القدس ووضع اليد
على منطقه غور الاردن اسرا اعلنت القدس
عاصمه للشعب اليهودي في العالم وليس
لاسرائيل فحسب هذا هي الحكومه هذا
الائتلاف الحاكم في اسرائيل هذا الكنيست
هذا الراي العام في اسرائيل الذي يتطرف
ويتجه نحو اليمين لم ينتج شريكا في عمليه
السلام واحسب اننا نضيع وقتا في هذا
المجال طيب ولكن كما سمعنا من السيد عزام
الاحمد واضح ان ابو مازن يذهب بسبب
الوساطه الاردنيه في النهايه الاردن عراب
هذا التحرك لماذا يذهب الاردن في هذا
اتجاه الاردن اعتقد انه يبذل محاوله اخيره
ان لم اقل يائسه في الحقيقه لاستئناف
المفاوضات وانقاذ عمليه السلام وفق تصور
ومفهوم استراتيجي اردني بان هذه العمليه
وما س قد تنتهي اليه من قيام دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله في الضفه
وعاصمتها القدس هي خط الدفاع الاول عن
المصالح الوطنيه العليا للاردن وليس فقط
مصلحه فلسطينيه الاردن يعتبر ان عدم قيام
هذه الدوله سوف يهدد امنه واستقراره وربما
وجوده وربما ينعش بشكل او باخر الحلول
والمحاولات الراميه لحل القضيه الفلسطينيه
خارج فلسطين على حساب الاردن وفلسطين معا
لذلك هو يحاول القيام باخر جهد اطلاق اخر
رصاصه في هذه العمليه ولكن في ظني انه
وبصرف النظر عن النوايا الاردنيه هذه
المحاوله مكتوب عليها بالفشل اسرائيليا
ومكتوب عليها بال فشل جراء الانحياز
الامريكي الدائم وغير
المشروط يعني اليس معني بالمصالحه ربما
بشكل اساسي عزام الاحمد يعني حماس عبرت عن
موقفها من هذا الاجتماع صراحه ووصفته يعني
اقتبس انه منزلق خطير تنزلق فيه السلطه
مجددا كما قالت وسيكون على حساب الشعب
الفلسطيني يعني هذه التحركات الا تهدد
مشروع مصالحه اصلا لم يتبلور بشكله الكامل
بدا يت بلبر
للتو لا اطلاقا ونحن متفاهم مع الاخوه في
حماس هذا موقفهم التقليدي ومن حقهم ان
يعلنوا هذا الموقف صباح مساء ولكن اود ان
اذكر في خطاب الاخ الد مشعل في عه خسه
عندما قال ليجرب الاخ ابو مازن سنه كامله
من المحاولات وفي اللقاء الاخير الذي حصل
او اللقائين بين الاخ ابو والاخ خالد مشعل
في القاهره في 24 نوفمبر الماضي وفي 22 او
21 ديسمبر الماضي ايضا يعني الاخ ابو مازن
كان واضح قال اذا ما توفرت اسس عمليه
السلام بشكل واضح واسس المفاوضات على اساس
وقف كامل للاستيطان
و مرجعيه عمليه السلامه الرابع من حزيران
عام 67 سنذهب والاخ خالد مشعل وحماس ايه
قالوا نحن منذ البدايه قلنا جربوا ولكن
انتم توصلتم يا اخ ابو مازن الى ان الطريق
مسدود وبالتالي نحن نثك بك ولكن هذا موقف
لحماس من حقها ان تاخذه ولا يهدد المصالحه
اطلاقا بل يعني نحن ما دمنا صرحاء مع
بعضنا البعض نضع النقاط على الحروف بشي لا
نخضع بعضنا البعض لنجرب كما
قال البعض ونضع اسرائيل ونكشف حقيقه
موقفها ونضع ايضا اللجنه الرباعيه وانتم
اشرتم الى تصريح الاخ ابو مازن اذا جاء 26
يناير ولم يحصل تقدم معنى ذلك كما قال
الاخ ابو مازن المفترض ان تذهب اللجنه
الرباعيه وبرنامجها وخططها الى الجحيم
لانها وقفت عاجزه عن القيام بتحمل
مسؤولياتها ساعود لموضوع 26 يناير هذ يعني
هذه نقطه مهمه ولكن اريد قبلها ان اسالك
عريب العنتابي فعلا يعني لماذا لا يسمح
لابو مازن بان يجرب في النهايه يعني يعطى
هامش من الحركه على الاقل كما قال عزام
الاحمد ليكشف الاطراف المتلاعبه
هنا يعني اعتقد ان اي بشكل او باخر لن
تكون هذه عقبه في وجه مسار المصالحه
واعتقد ان الاخوه في حماس بالذات يعني
قياده حماس في الخارج اعتقد انها يعني
باتت اكثر تفهما ربما لهذا السياق اعتقد
اذا اذا اذا اذا تورطت القياده الفلسطينيه
في استئناف المفاوضات دون الحصول على
مطالبها وشروطها بوقف الاستيطان واعتماد
مرجعيه الرابع من حزيران اساسا لهذه
المفاوضات عندها في ظني ان الطاوله سوف
تقلب على راس الجميع ولن يكون هناك مصالحه
وسوف تشهد الساحه الفلسطينيه انقسامات
اضافيه بدل الانقسام القديم السابق لكن في
ظني اننا امام محاوله يائسه محكوم عليها
بالفشل جراء التعنت الاسرائيلي اساسا
واعتقد ان حضور الفلسطينيين الى عمان فيه
قدر ربما من الحرص على العلاقه مع الاردن
والمجامله للاردن هذا الاجتماع ياتي
تتويجا لمبادره اطلقها الملك بالذات في
رام الله واعتقد ان الجانب الفلسطيني لا
يرغب ان يظهر امام الاردن بمظهر المعرقل
لمحاولته الاخيره هذه ولهذا السبب في ظني
ان الحكم على انعكاسات هذه الخطوه على
المصالحه الفلسطينيه سوف ياتي عشيه اليوم
التالي لاجتماعات عمان عندما نعرف ان
اسرائيل لن تلتزم لا بوقف الاستيطان ولا
بمرجع الرابع من حزيران ولا باي جداول
زمنيه الحقيقه الراسخه الوحيده الثابته ان
ليس في اسرائيل شريك لعمليه السلام هذا
امر تدركه القياده الفلسطينيه وتدركه حماس
واعتقد ان ما عدا ذلك يصبح في اللحظه
الراهنه على الاقل بعض التفاصيل وسنرى ذلك
في غضون الساعات ال 48 القادمه ارجو ان
تبقوا معنا فاصل قصير نواصل بعده
[موسيقى]
النقاش اهلا بكم من جديد الى حلقتنا التي
تتناول افق تحركات اللجنه الرباعيه
وتهديدات عباس باعتماد خيارات بديله في
حال فشلها في استئناف المفاوضات اذا عزام
الاحمد كنت اشرت الى المهله التي اعلنها
بوضوح ابو مازن يوم 26
يناير ضمن اي رؤيه تعلن هذه
المهله
يعني اعطينا عمليه السلام فرص عديده وحتى
هذا اللقاء في عمان هي فرصه
اضافيه رغم انني اتفق انا شخصيا مع الاخ
ريب لا نتوقع ان يحدث تغير دراماتيكي من
الجانب الاسرائيلي بل التحضيرات التي تجري
الى الان ربما تلجا اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده الى استغلال الاجتماع للتسويف
ومحاوله كسب الوقت والتمديد اسبوع اسبوعين
ثلاثه موقفنا واضح لا لبس فيه لن نقبل ان
يكون هذا اللقاء وسيله للابتزاز
للقفز على استحقاق 26 يناير وبالتالي وهو
الموعد لسنا الذين نحن حددناه وانما
اللجنه الرباعيه هي التي حددته عندما طلبت
من الجانبين ردود حول موضوع الامن وحول
الحدود وهما جوهر عمليه السلام اسرائيل
تتهرب لانها لا تريد ان تنخرط في عمليه
سلام والولايات المتحده تقف عاج زه خاصه
الان كما كانت عاجزه سابقا ولكن في هذا
الوقت بالذات مع مزاد الانتخابات الامريكي
تحاول ايضا ان تستند كما جرت العاده
تقليديا عليه نحن نقول لن نقبل ان يجري
تمديد او استغلال لهذا اللقاء لكسب
الوقت على ماذا تهن يعني ابو مازن استبعد
العمل العسكري استبعد الانفا
مشروع الامم المتحده في الواقع صب عليه
ماء باردا بامتياز ما هي الخيارات التي
يتحدث عنها ابو
مازن يعني شوفي انا بقول بشكل واضح بغض
النظر عن تصريحات الاخ ابو مازن قضيه
انتفاضه ومش انتفاضه لا تؤخذ بقرار كفاح
مسلح وتغيير اشكال النضال لا يؤخذ فجاه
بقرار عندما يعلن ذلك الاخ ابو مازن فهو
يؤكد التزام منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
بخيار السلام والمفاوضات ولكن عندما يصل
الى لحظه الحقيقه ويقول ان اللجنه
الرباعيه فشلت معنى ذلك انتقلنا الى مرحله
جديده تحتاج الى اجابات ما العمل بعد ذلك
والاخ ابو مازن منذ عده اشهر وجه سؤال
للقياده الفل ينيه جميعها كل الفصائل وحتى
وجه السؤال في الاجتماع الاخير في القاهره
للاخوه الذين لا يشاركوا في اجتماعات
منظمه التحرير وهم حماس والجهاد الاسلامي
باعتبارهم جزء من الحركه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه من واجبهم ايضا ان يجيبوا على
هذا السؤال اذا ما تعثرت الامور في
26/1 واغلقت الابواب امام
مفاوضات ما العمل هذا مطروح للاجابه من
السابق لاوانه ان نبدا نفصل ما هي الخطوات
الاخرى لا ولكن اعتقد انه سؤال مشروع يعني
ان نسال يعني عن الاقل خيارات يعني ممكن
ان تطرح ضعنا في صوره خيارات موجوده ط
صحيح انا بتقديري معنى جمود عمليه السلام
معنى جمود عمليه السلام فتح الابواب امام
عوده الفوضى ودائره العنف الى المنطقه ليس
في الساحه الفلسطينيه والمجابهة
اجابات جديده وهي ربما متجدده ليست يعني
يكون المسؤول عنها انا بتقديري هو الموقف
الاسرائيلي وموقف الولايات المتحده بشكل
خاص وعز المجتمع الدولي والرباعيه وتصبح
الابواب مفتوحه امام كل الخيارات امام كل
الخيارات واؤكد امام كل الخيارات بما فيها
العمل العسكري بما فيها
الانتفاضه
قتوم ليس من حق اي شخص ان يجاوب الكل
الفلسطيني مطلوب منه ان
يجاوب يعني من ينتقد عباس لا يريده ان
يذهب الى عمان لا يريده ان يذهب الى الامم
المتحده ولكن يعني اذا اردنا ان ننظر
واقعيا الى الخيارات الموجوده امام ابو
مازن كيف تراها
انت يا سيدتي يعني نحن الان في مناخ
فلسطيني مغاير يعني القوى الفلسطينيه
الرئيسه تكاد تكون توافقت على ملامح
المرحله المقبله ربما لم يكن لم يتبلور
بعد الاتفاق بصيغه النهائيه ولكن مما تبين
لنا من اجتماعات القاهره منذ ايار حتى
يومنا هذا في الحقيقه هناك ملامح
استراتيجيه فلسطينيه بديله قيد التشكل هذه
الاستراتيجيه تفترض اولا الشروع في مسار
المصالحه حتى نهايه المطاف بما في ذلك
اعاده بناء المؤسسه الفلسطينيه من منظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه التي يجب اعاده بنائها
فورا وتفعيلها فورا وبدون ابطاء الى
السلطه الفلسطينيه التي يتعين اعاده تعريف
وظائفها وادوارها واجراء الانتخابات
لتشكيل مؤسساتها بهذا المعنى الى تشكيل
الحكومه قبل ذلك التي تشرف على الانتخابات
الحره والنزيه ومشاركه الجميع بعد ذلك
الانتقال الى ترجمه المقاومه الشعبيه من
شعار توافقت عليه القوى الفلسطينيه
الاساسيه فت وحماس بشكل خاص اعاده ترجمه
هذه المقوله من شعار سياسي عام الى
استراتيجيه وطنيه على الارض يجري تبنيها
في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه الى ملاحقه
اسرائيل
ومطاردتها في مختلف المحافل والمنابر
الحقوقيه والسياسيه والاعلاميه والجماهريه
الدوليه من لهاي الى القضاء المحلي في كل
دوله الى حقوق الانسان في جنيف الى الامم
المتحده الى احياء موضوع الاعتراف
بالدوله الفلسطينيه كل هذه المسارات ينبغي
ان تكون مفتوحه ومفتوحه على عندما يقول
عز ان كل الخيارات مفتوحه يعني هل ترى ان
هناك شيء من التحول في موقف السلطه
التاريخي الحوار والسلام خيار
استراتيجي اعتقد ان السلطه وصلت الى طريق
مسدود فيما خص خيار التفاوض هذا الخيار
وصل الى طريق مسدود 26 واح الذي تحدث عنه
الرئيس ابو مازن هو الاذان بنهايه اخر
فرصه ولا ينبغي ان يكون هناك فرص مفتوحه
تحت اي ظرف وهذه المساله لا تجوز معها
المجامله لا مجامله اي دوله شقيقه او
صديقه او دوله منفرده او رباعيه او غير
ذلك بعد السا من يناير الجاري ينبغي ان
ينتقل الجسم القيادي الفلسطيني الى ترجمه
ما اتفق عليه في القاهره الى وضع ملامح
الاستراتيجيه الجديده برنامج العمل الوطني
الفلسطيني الجديد الذي اشرنا الى بعض
ملامحه وعناوينه وخطوطه لا يجب البقاء
يعني في حاله انتظار لا يجب الانتقال من
مهله الى مهله اخرى مفتوحه اسرائيل تناور
اسرائيل تراوغ نتنياهو يكذب نتنياهو يستمر
في الاستيطان وفي التوسع وفي التهويد وفي
وضع اليد على الارض والحقوق الفلسطينيه
وهذه سنه انتخابات امريكيه واوربيه العالم
منصرف الى قضايا اخرى يجب استغلال هذه
الفتره لبلوره الوضع الفلسطيني الداخلي
بناء الجبهه الداخليه تصليب البيت الداخلي
الفلسطيني الانتقال الى المقاومه الشعبيه
بكل اشكالها المقاومه السلميه كما جرى
التوافق على ذلك في القاهره هذه عناوين
يجب ان ننتقل اليها فورا ومن دون ابطاء
ولا تحتمل الانتظار والتاجيل والمهل
الزمنيه هذا هو البرنامج الوطني الفلسطيني
الذي تكاد تجمع عليه مختلف الفصائل فلنذهب
اليه ولنذهب اليه بلا تردد هذا هو المطلوب
الان اذا مجرد وقت تضيعون عزام
الاحمد لا لا نضيع الوقت بالعكس نحن نحاول
ان نستغل كل دقيقه وكما قلت نحن ضد الجمود
ولكن الموقف يوم 261 في اليوم التالي
سيكون مختلف تماما ولا نريد ان
نفسد اجبتنا قبل ان نتفق عليها بشكل نهائي
الكل الفلسطيني وعندما قلت ان الجميع
مطلوب منهم ان يشاركوا في الاجابه على
سؤال الرئيس ابو مازن بما فيها حماس
والجهاد الاسلامي وكل فصائل منظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه ف معنى ذلك ان وحده الشعب
الفلسطيني مجتمعه ستعطي الرد وكما قلت
خياراتنا ستكون يعني مشروعه ومفتوحه على
مصرعيها في ضوء التطورات اللاحقه عزام
الاحمد عضو اللجنه المركزيه لحركه فتح
شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من رام الله وشكرا
جزيلا لعريب الرنتاوي مدير مركز القدس
للدراسات السياسيه من عمان وشكرا لكم
مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
حلقه جديده في
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ملا
c